their man's best friend and according to
research our trusted sleeping partner
too
two-thirds of pet owners now share a bed
with their cat or dog a new poll
suggests the survey of 2 000 people by
Sleep Brands Silent Night also
discovered that nearly one-third do so
every single night but should we really
be letting uh dogs share our beds while
exposure to mites from pets can
strengthen the immune system experts say
The Habit can run the risk of serious
infection sharing your bed with your dog
increases the chance of them
transferring microbes that sit on a
dog's skin possibly via licking feces or
from their fur such bugs can cause
conditions including mange or even Lyme
disease
you can get mange okay you could become
a mangy Beast just like your dog
Professor Alejandra parati a might
expert at the school of biological
sciences says if a dog owner is immuno
Con immunocompromised or has a weak
immune system even temporarily then they
should not share their bed with a dog
yeah if you're immune to compromise you
shouldn't share your baby look also if
you have any dignity at all as a human
being you shouldn't share your bed with
a dog
in summary it goes on with all the
different disgusting diseases that you
can get uh but but the summary is don't
sleep with a dog in your bed you Savages
what are you are you a barn animal
you're laying in bed with a flea covered
Beast right next to you you might as
well sleep on a bed of hay on in the
dirt okay you might as well do that
go go get some some goats and pigs and
just sleep in their pin with them their
pen rather with everything going on in
the world sometimes you just need a
break from it all choose today to
strengthen your faith despite this
broken world through prayer meditation
and fasting Hollow helps me maintain a
daily prayer routine it gives me a break
from the craziness around me if you need
a break uh well you need Hallows the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
U.S download the app for free at
hello.com Matt Walsh you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress along
the way not sure where to start well a
good place to start is uh father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year available on
the hollow app for brief daily Bible
readings and Reflections or you could
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes as well with how low you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen anywhere you are
with downloadable offline sessions
there's no better time to stay rooted in
your faith and values get an exclusive
three-month free trial at hello.com Matt
Walsh that's hello.com Matt Walsh
if you don't want to behave like a human
being
you might as well cut to the chase
and
act like an I'm telling you this is our
real problem as a society it's maybe not
the only problem but it is a real
problem they say that they said in the
article dogs are a man's best friend
okay like I don't they're not my best
friend okay I think your friends should
be humans but but fine
well guess what friends need boundaries
the dog is your friend fine do you do
you sleep in bed with your friends
especially if you're a man do you do you
let your friends lick your face
if you saw your friend licking his own
butt would you then let him lick would
you be his friend anymore in the first
place
let's be serious okay
don't let the dog if you want to have a
dog and a pet whatever fine but let and
then you smell you smell like a dog and
no one tells you
you're sleeping in dog scented
sheets and blankets
and you and you're walking out of the
house smelling like a dog
but nobody will tell you that you smell
that way
and part of the reason is that 60 of the
rest of the of the country also smells
like dogs
and then the rest of us were walking
around and while we're smelling his dog
everywhere
dog and and the scent of dogs and weed
that is like America right that's this
that is what America smells like you get
you if you come here from another
country you land you get off the plane
it's immediately what you smell because
that's just everywhere and I'll do it
for this portion of shows move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]